[Musique]
et on s'arrête sur la campagne pour
l'élection présidentielle française
c'est dans moins d'un mois maintenant
vous le savez avec à mes côtés à chaque
verdure bonjour h rennes france 2022
l'heure du choix qui s'intéresse
aujourd'hui aux candidats jean luc
mélenchon oui après son grand
rassemblement dimanche place de la
république à paris qui a réuni des
dizaines de milliers de personnes cent
mille selon les organisateurs
c'est le plus grand rassemblement
politique depuis le début de la campagne
objectif pour jean luc mélenchon le
second tour il y croit plus que jamais
et pour mobiliser son électorat y promet
comme à son habitude l'avènement d'un
nouveau monde d'une nouvelle république
la 6e ou le peuple reprendra le pouvoir
un peuple à qui il a aussi mis la
pression dimanche l'appelant être
responsable pour éviter le scénario de
2010 est à savoir un duel final macron
le pen le récap politique est signée
florent rodo et nicolas ouvert
c'est l'histoire d'un rêve nommé sixième
république
jean luc mélenchon peut avoir le sourire
comme il y a cinq ans les rues de paris
sont noires de monde à son appel
l'occasion de se dresser en opposant
numéro un au président candidat
choisi c'est trash et la retraite à 65
ans avec maquereau ou la retraite à 60
ans avec mélenchon il a beau partager
quelques unes de ses idées pas question
pour autant de se ranger derrière
l'insoumis ne venez surtout pas parler à
fabien roussel de vote utile à gauche
nous l'avons fait en 2012 ou en 2017 et
salah n'a pas permis à la gauche de
l'emporter au premier tour d'une
élection présidentielle
on vote pour ses idées on vote pour ses
convictions
lui est convaincu d'être le sauveur de
la france et il en assume toute
l'histoire pour eric zemmour la
colonisation a du bon du très bon même
moi qui suis d'origine berbère j'ai été
colonisé par les arabes d'algérie qui
gouvernent aujourd'hui le pays j'ai été
ensuite colonisés par la france et je
vous répète moi je bénis la colonisation
française ça m'a permis de venir à paris
vous savez je ne considère pas que la
colonisation fut un crime contre
l'humanité jean emmanuel
macron emmanuel macron justement il
honoré dimanche à toulouse la mémoire de
victimes de mohamed merah à ses côtés
ses deux prédécesseurs à l'elysée
françois hollande et nicolas sarkozy
dont valérie pécresse attend toujours
désespérément le soutien
en 2012 si les candidats parler beaucoup
terrorisme dix ans plus tard c'est le
pouvoir d'achat qui tracte la campagne
et marine le pen l'a bien compris la
politique c'est l'art des choix moi je
fais des choix et donc je fais des
économies et je rends leur argent aux
français je veux leur rendre l'argent
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve demain
et on l'a vu donc meeting réussi pour
jean luc mélenchon
hier dimanche s'il on en croit en tout
cas à l'affluence 1 place de la
république à paris affluence d'ailleurs
confirmé par un sondage ifop qui place
désormais jean luc mélenchon en
troisième position c'était déjà le cas
dans un certain nombre d' enquêtes
d'opinion mais avec 14%
effectivement ça se confirme cette
troisième position derrière donc
emmanuel macron crédité de 28 % et
marine le pen à dix huit et demi
pourcent arrive en quatrième position
valérie pécresse à 10 et demi pour son à
noter aussi que fabien roussel est
crédité de 400 loin devant anne hidalgo
à 2% les intentions de vote c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de la vème
république que moi un candidat
communiste devance ainsi un candidat
socialiste sondage après sondage en tout
cas vous l'avez vu la dynamique
mélenchon se confirme elle aussi
l'espoir pour lui de tourner la page de
la frustration 2017 lorsqu'il avait
échoué de justesse à accéder au second
tour cette fois-ci est la bonne ses
partisans en sont convaincus reportage
de fadil bayat et juliette monty
un dimanche ensoleillé une ambiance
festive c'est la recette de jean-luc
mélenchon pour cette grande marche pour
une sixième république
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
doucement mais sûrement c'est la
stratégie de jean luc mélenchon le
candidat de l'union populaire est
désormais troisième dans les intentions
de vote selon plusieurs sondages un seul
mot d'ordre mobiliser ce qu'on appelle
classiquement le peuple de gauche il n'a
pas disparu la question pour nous c'est
pas de se demander si on va prendre sur
l'électorat de jado aux autres la
question pour nous c'est de réveiller
des gens qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas envie
de voter entre soutien à la résistance
ukrainienne retraite à 60 ans smic à
1400 euros ou encore le gel du prix des
carburants pendant près d'une heure le
candidat a galvanisé la foule
le moral des troupes est au plus haut
aujourd'hui ça a été un des
démonstrations de force folle il ya eu
plein de générations il y avait des
poussettes y avait des fdd personnes
âgées avaient nous des jeunes de la fac
et on a été ton étaient tous fiers on
chantait tous les mêmes champs on était
tous notés tous contents d'être là
aujourd'hui on a des gens qui nous
disent moi je me tais plus est
hélas ils votent en fait ils me disent
oh là pour cette élection en 2022 c'est
possible le monde dans lequel on vit
n'est plus possible donc bah oui on va
aller voter et on va aller voter jean
luc mélenchon et donc ça fait du bien ça
fait plaisir et on voit que ça
fonctionne en fait ce souffle d'espoir
ces dizaines de milliers de soutiens de
mélenchon espère le retrouver dans les
urnes le 10 avril prochain
et on en vient à présent à l'appel 1 2
jean luc mélenchon à une union populaire
qui pourrait le permet d'accéder lui
permet d'accéder au second tour un
chouette oui vous l'avez entendu jean
luc mélenchon s'est positionné comme le
principal opposant à emmanuel macron et
à son programme dévoilé jeudi dernier
pour le leader de la france insoumise
les votes le vote des 10 et 24 avril
prochains et un référendum sociales
notamment donc sur l'âge de départ à la
retraite emmanuel macron je me rappelle
veut le repousser à 65 ans on en parle
ce soir avec notre éditorialiste
politique roselyne febvre bonsoir
roselyne jean luc mélenchon peut-il
souffle il a se replace à marine le pen
écoutez il en rêve en tout cas c'est un
rêve éveillé pour emmanuel macron pour
jean luc mélenchon pardon être le
véritable adversaire en fait du candidat
sortant mais à regarder les sondages
vous l'avez dit eh bien il est à 14 %
donc à quatre points de marine le pen
mais marine le pen est extrêmement
solide pour l'instant sur ses fondations
à un électorat qui lui est fidèle dans
le dernier sondage d'ailleurs l'écart se
réduit entre macro est elle alors jean
luc mélenchon peut rêver ce n'est pas
interdit à trois semaines du scrutin
mais
je veux dire avec les bagnoles 2
jean-luc décidément je les confonds jean
luc mélenchon à 3 à 3 à tous est un
tribun hors pair il sait innover on l'a
vu dans ses meetings il sait raconter il
raconte bien et on l'écouté ne remplit
pas quand on écoute jean luc mélenchon
il parle des sujets différents des
autres de la souffrance animale de la
guerre dans l'espace et puis il est
habile un peu comme gérard majax est le
magicien à dire qu'il sait faire
disparaître ce qui l'encombrent et en
l'occurrence son
antiaméricanisme qui au début de la
guerre a débouché sur forcément un
soutien à poutine et bien il disait que
l'agresseur s'était les états unis dont
qu'il a il a réussi à inverser la
tendance et hier il a dit beaucoup de
mal des méchants russes il a su faire
oublier aussi que son modèle économique
s'était go chavez celui qui a quand même
mis à terre l'économie du venezuela il
et adorateurs de robespierre à mais
comme l'a écrit marcel gauchet et bien
robespierre c'est l'homme qui divisent
les français pour les uns il est
l'incorruptible pour les autres il est
un tyran sanguinaire mais tout de même
robespierre parce que c'est ce qui va
flatter jean luc mélenchon chez
robespierre c'est l'homme de la vertu
seul homme de la morale et on sait ce
que in fine est ça a donné bref jean luc
mélenchon est aussi à l'image d'eric
zemmour celui qui clivent mais c'est
celui aussi qui commémorera compte
quelque chose on va dire qu'il a un
récit est tous les deux
attirent l'attention parce que il parle
de quelque chose qu'on soit d'accord ou
pas mais quand on regarde de près son
programme
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué est ce
qu'on l'imaginait l'elysée vous l'avez
dit comment retourner à la retraite à 60
ans alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est 62 ans et
qu'on sait que le déficit et est pour
l'instant abyssal pas dans plusieurs
années mais c'est maintenant que le
déficit des retraites est là il ne dit
pas comment comment le comble augmenter
le smic à 1400 euros alors est-ce que ça
va pas pénaliser
les entreprises le blocage des prix de
première nécessité comment fait-il
l'amnestie pour tous les gilet jaune qui
ont été condamnés c'est l'autorité qui
en prend un coup le projet est il viable
est ce que le projet du yaka fokon est
il viable et bien c'est je vous laisse
juge de sept de ses propositions face à
cette hypothèse donc dû d'un second tour
en présence de jean luc mélenchon
s'inquiète à l'elysée pas du tout pas du
tout parce qu'elle elysée on regarde
cette petite bête qui monte qui monte et
il ne panique pas bien au contraire
pourquoi parce que au deuxième tour et
bien on considère que jean luc mélenchon
n'a pas de réserve de voix que les
socialistes de voteront jamais pour lui
même si on prend sa calculette et qu on
fait le total gauche on arrive à 25 % et
on n'atteint pas les 28% et puis s'il
était au second tour certains et bien à
droite
ayant peur de voir débouler jean luc
mélenchon votre aide pour emmanuel
macron merci beaucoup rosine on vous
retrouve demain dans mardi politique
vous recevrez la députée aurore bergé
président délégué du groupe la
république en marche à l'assemblée
nationale un cycle député la france
insoumise alexis corbière qui est
d'ailleurs l'un des maillons forts de la
campagne de jean luc mélenchon on en
vient nous à notre bonus du jour oui
raphaël un journal décidément quasiment
100% mélenchon ce soir une archive du 22
mai 2002 il y a quasiment vingt ans jour
pour jour archives d'un accrochage entré
dans les annales il s'est produit lors
du premier débat télévisé de marine le
pen envoyé à l'époque par son père
jean-marie sur le plateau de nos
confrères de france 3 pour défendre les
idées du front national donc ancêtre du
renseignement national en amont des
législatives de juin 2002 marine le pen
attaque jean luc mélenchon qui fait
alors partie de l'ailé gauche du parti
socialiste
l attaque sur le thème des hommes
politiques tous pour y écouter il
souffre beaucoup monsieur mélenchon
notamment un des critiques qui sont
faites aux politiques et pourtant qu'est
ce que vous les méritez un parce que qui
a contribué à faire croire aux français
que l'intégralité des hommes politiques
étaient malhonnêtes c'est vous et c'est
vous parce que vous parce que parce que
mais oui bien sûr partie mais qui a
laissé la caisse claire l'udf et le pc
et c'est tout pour ce soir merci h reine
de france 2022 lors du show on se
retrouve demain pour la suite de la
chronique présidentielle et nous pour un
nouveau journal est bien dans 5 minutes
dans paris direct reste avec
[Musique]